welcome back to Boston I'm joined now
with Steph Curry stuff first thank you
so much it's been a really difficult
week and it's great to have you on and
talk to you I know you can compute a lot
against Kobe you guys are friends I
we're gonna get to Kobe the player but I
want to start with Kobe the man and the
father your father beautiful children
and you have daughters and when you
heard this news how did it hit you and
what did you tell those beautiful girls
not like that you can say about you know
how much code mentos and off the floor
and you see like the point of via videos
and just the the way that he embraced
his kids every single chance he did or
he could and what he shared you know his
career and just love with each and every
single one of them so I mean honestly
this whole situation sucks and you pray
for the family that did this whole
process as a father knowing the whole
that he's not able to feel anymore and
obviously for GG too so I know the whole
NBA family whole world really has a bet
through tragedy it's somehow unifying
all of us which is the duty of it when
it comes to Kobe the basketball player
what do you admire most about him and
what do you want people to remember
about his game and the competitor that
he was that's the one of the toughest
parts about this week because you didn't
really I know as I was coming up in the
game he was the guy that you know
imitating his moves on the court and
anytime he was on TV he wanted to watch
and lock you know what he was doing as
you say he was always about greatness
and you appreciate that so much
[Applause]
remember the first game back at the for
my preseason preseason my rookie year
like how amazing a moment that was we're
sitting there asking for like yourself
like I want to see me so much he has a
presence that we all understood how much
basketball meant to him and he pushed
the game to new heights and we are all
better for it
well you're a class act we know it's
been a really hard couple of days so we
appreciate you coming on frame for you
moving forward to
[Music]